but before we started to make the film
did you do any preparation aside from
obviously studying the script and and
connecting with the character what sort
of preparation did you do for well first
of all I never had the book and then if
you'll recall mr. Friedkin we had a very
long time before we started shooting and
you took me to the Metropolitan Museum
took 8 paintings on a Monday when the
museum was closed and we had it all to
ourselves we played music together
you showed me photographs including the
magret that you used for the famous ad
for the film you showed me the books
that had been written about the research
that was done on the real case you
filled me with information and
background and understanding of what I
was getting myself in for so I was very
well prepared by you by the time we went
into rehearsal so thank you sir that's
great but you also were raised Catholic
weren't you I was but you weren't
Catholic at the time we made the film oh
I wasn't Catholic from 17 on
[Applause]
and I guess you're still not a Catholic
I'm still okay but what did you make of
this stuff outside of the fact that it's
obviously a wonderful role that you
completely fulfilled fulfilled and what
did you make of the idea of possession
and exorcism itself well I know that
it's happened you know I read the
material on the actual case of the boy
but I know throughout history you know
there's that wonderful play the Dybbuk
which is a Jewish version of The
Exorcist
but older certainly there are many
ancient writings about people being
possessed by spirits I don't pretend to
know I only know that there's more to
the universe than we have any idea about
and I don't tie myself down to one
belief system that says okay this is the
way it is I live in a state of awe and
gratitude that the universe keeps
surprising us and unfolding more and
more of its complexity to us in so many
different ways so I don't rule out
anything and in my life the metaphysical
expresses itself to the physical many
times in in many different ways so I'm
open to it all and grateful for every
bit of revelation that comes